blog mas numero 5 sono e guglielmo del
futuro e come c'è anche il gould del
futuro vi chiedo già scusa per quello
che vedrete in questo blog sarà il
delirio totale vi chiedo perdono
ma se vi piace causa della nostra
famiglia mettete già un pollice in su
sulla fiducia questa mattina il mio
gatto maschio utilizzato il mio letto
come qua letta e vorrei capire perchè lo
fanno vestiti sono adorabile cialmente
col mio gatto maschio a quello rosso pa
devono sapere qui nei commenti per
favore sono distrutto oggi ragazzi ma
c'è un gatto dell'albero è lì e poi
eccolo lì ha visto normale che un altro
fatto una simile peso una pallina una
domanda per chi capri è venuto io ho
un'altra domanda perché che a breve
ancora i pantaloni è successo niente
nella spiaggia subito detto gli occhiali
no ecco qui tanti problemi che un filone
luce funziona lega che hanno fulminato
tutte le luci dell'albero azzurro lo
abbiamo verificato attacco sai anche che
penso sia fatto la tua gatta femmina che
stamattina me la sono ritrovata la testa
che sbucava da qui perché non è bravo
come me ed educare i gatti e le
pubblicità progresso
sul tema bambini hanno magari capire uno
stuntman che sta facendo un secondo il
giornale eticamente questa scena così
l'ho trovato il mio libro semplici
readers award estera passa minuti
nessuno di voi ha calcolato che in
quell'anno si sono attaccati ad una
presa però noi abbiamo una pronuncia noi
in alcun conto
ora voglio vederti scendere gianmarco
[Musica]
[Risate]
palettina però queste cose non si fanno
io non sopravvivono che ha visto che ti
stai muovendo
gabriele io non ci credo che tu non ti
sei preso il mac con noi guarda che
quanto ami il mac mac
però se fanno schifo pranzo e cena è
finita
io faccio schifo pranzo e cena io non
parla da colazione io guarda sai come
inganno la cosa mi trovai a del nec per
non pensarci perché non posso pensare
anche leva sente gradi mentre
congelamento canto che vuol dire di una
canzone al mac come se fosse un amore
perduto anche tu così presente tu che
sempre non era il mio amore per mac è un
amore non corrisposto continuare così o
deliri di vernice non posso forzarti
credimi mi chiede io posso solo
indicarci la via sei tu che la devi
attraversare propriamente abbastanza
importante allora cala un po più bassa
malore non sia anche prova di coraggio
della settimana resistere al netto di un
altro la nostra
già finita per nuovi giorni
no ai software i soldi qui ancora un
abisso quindi vedere camera cazzo questo
danno grave per in grado 1 rosso però è
buonissimo lo stesso né anzi forse è
ancora merita una persona meno
schizzinosa del credito che immagino il
mondo mani quando avrai palle di pelo
turismo psicologiche rifaccio alle due
male di te lo faccio questo
confessionale come va nella casa va bene
i ragazzi sono tutti simpatici tempera
di conoscerli da una vita
vado d'accordo con tutti non voglio
nominare nessuno sono qui per questo
confessionale ma vanno anche fare altro
possiamo creare sciarpe di natale
pardini a smr degli stipendi
[Musica]
si può fare anche se prof però devo
nominare per forza non meno il panino è
caduto per terra
chi l'ha portato o chi l'ha confezionato
perché se il panino fosse stato
assemblato bene non sarebbe caduto non
avrebbe avuto quello squilibrio
sull'avanti ha fatto sì che cadesse
dall'amata altro nome sono io
così veniva da un messaggio d'aiuto metà
temi andare via come l'agente smith sono
saturo di questa casa di questo settore
potrà continuare a guardare così per
sempre e il suono dello scaldabagno
ruano mach iii b e top prego angoli qui
fuori il naso mi è passato seller guardi
scelto subito se volete scappato ma così
agguantato un pò letto divorando mi
amano anche pazzesco lazio andato
proprio guardate a kabul è stato lui
andrà che uno con questa faccenda possa
aver commesso un crimine del genere è
quasi riuscito nel suo intento bene
quasi moto anche mia moglie mi rieti pre
cornuto il supporto di un queste persone
ma di moto guardami non sortire il
momento aggiunto nel fortino quasi vada
tu che privato la schizzinosa vorresti
per mangiare questi tu sei pazzo cioè
franci bulldog ma sembra perfetto
ragazzi ma terminata bocciare la legge
dei croccantini se non sono quello di da
pasqua e non che pure abbiamo io col
camper o no
la salle garnier hanno perso niente cosa
mi manca la faccia momento la challenge
a tutte le palle babbo natale vicino
campo cassano sembra pareggiando le
cavolate una challenge per ogni cosa
facciamo questi bei giorni vostri
prendete quasi usatelo come supposto
invitiamo la testa di quasi nel baratto
di appello nel latte aspetto il secondo
me fiore una volta perché no eh sì
perché oggi lavorano già stato carlo c'è
l'america marilyn fanno schifo gli
omogeneizzati per umani figure di quelli
liberi cattivi preferiscono un già lunga
mi dispiace ma avverte masse bellissimo
chiamato hinton giorno ragazzi all
italia valentina per 10 minuti parlare
della sua vita amorosa mai farli parlare
con valentina vicino alla finestra e
capire cosa è meno peggio tra le due
cose la challenge vinto la challenge
mangia
una gamba rotta quanti riusciamo a
sederci sulla sedia rotelle con voi una
challenge venire allora la challenge
agli sparecchia prima a chi toglie
questa merda landini si rifà il letto
per primo viene diventa fan page è la
solita maledetta ma challenge guarda
guarda cosa c'è dietro la tenda come le
cose più magiche di temerari challenge
pazzesca retinico toglie ribelli dai
divani però se c'è questa è la challenge
che voglio vedere fare la differenza è
divertito hai fatto il tuo show ora si
gioca allora chi riesce a fare il motto
un challenge sicuramente non mangia
troppo logica anno commenti perché state
lanciando utili in un male
allah ci credo non ci credo tale ma
com'è che si capisce di delicate c'è
un'altra semifinale un girone di
perdenti e poi il perdente mangia 123456
peso pro capite il vincitore se lo
mangia glassato grazie io l'ho fatto
bene ma non ci fa capire roma lanciata
ma scusa non passò la notte senza
pensarci recupero animali riunita il
giro mangiare mi rimetto in gioco è una
challenge bellissima dovresti farla a
casa mi piace insomma ho studiato
movimenti la settima male dai ragazzi
posso dire che la vita ti maggiorata
subito e croccantini pare che questa fa
tanto meglio il gioco gioco col cazzo
che mi rimetto in gioco grandi grandi
tutti proprio col cazzo in vita gabriele
enrico fuori regione
alla prossima croccantino lascia londra
la paura croccantino c'è un uomo per
viene chiesto di risolvere un enigma
premi ai mano di tempo che non ci riesce
e sul tempo che non ci riesce a una
settimana di tempo e non ci riesce a un
certo punto fu l'uomo viene detto è il
giorno di tempo top diciotti verrà tolta
la vita è quell'uomo momento 5 liane
ha già messo alle strette fra usa e
racconterò la storia un giorno era una
donna su sei non ne posso andare senza
paure mangiando
consapevoli della banda
no no dalla ciotola sbagliata
ragazzi io propongo questa cosa l'umido
non oggi perché secondo me è tardi naca
dobbiamo muoverci
io non so se saremo presenti nel social
viola stasera alle 19 detto ciò raga
l'umido non c'è tempo a 100.000 like 6
mania mature l'umido milano rimargina a
50.000 like enrico si mangia a 50.000
like c'era giochiamo con i ragazzi
guglielmo impazzito 15 tocca l'ingrato
compito della chiusura del video era
qualcosa che sono un po provato dalla
sfida sinceramente non penso proprio
magari domani magari un'altra volta
magari da che ha bombardato la ecco così
nota giovane ferito perché il posto di
che non erano così malvagi capire mi
disse così quel giorno tante anche
cambiò le disse così e guardano ragazzi
se vedevo trovati dai